[Music]
[Applause]
and uh Diana Rossini kind enough to join
us there who's whose trophy is that
whose office are you in right now at the
Mothership
I love that you know that I'm not good
enough to have my own
so I am in someone else's office and I
figured if I'm gonna go in an office I
gotta make sure this is like the
Superstar office at ESPN so this is
actually Stephen A Smith's
um office at the South Street Seaport
you got the cowboy the black cowboy hat
on you got his cigar you got a trophy
that's the size of you
I mean what is he even getting this for
it's out this is great Daniel love this
the goat broadcaster award is what this
is oh I I didn't know there was a real
Award with that okay yeah I apologize
that you did not win it this year
2019. you did not win it but there's
hope for 2023. I'll see who I can talk
to to make sure you try to win this
thing but yeah you learn a lot about a
person sitting in their office and
there's not much to Stephen A everything
about him is here
hats and trophies that basically tell
them how great he is he's that simple of
a man uh well here we're here to tell
you how great you've been with uh the
coverage of Aaron Rodgers and the Jets
that everybody went out to visit with
him what are the Jets selling do we know
what are they selling to Aaron Rodgers
what's the pitch yeah they're selling
the
they're going from
what they have to give him that was what
I was told that that was that was sort
of the opening line of pay
this team is built to win now we're not
we're not doing this to grow
um and it was a very similar pitch to
Derek Carr by the way
um in terms of trying to let these
quarterbacks know that they're just one
talented guy away from what they believe
you know is to get deep in the playoffs
and part you know you know they want a
Super Bowl let's just say they're trying
to go for a Super Bowl but okay you
mentioned Derek Carr what were the Jets
leaning towards him was he leaning
towards them I'm just curious about how
this worked that now we're on Aaron
Rodgers and Derek cars in New Orleans
yeah this was all going on over the
weekend and you know every time I was
checking in with both sides and everyone
around the league who was in the
conversations it seems like
the Jets were in on Derek Carr right you
heard some of the reports that that I
shared about how they were pitching this
Jets roster as well they were they
believe in what he could do what he
could bring to New York his own legacy
could change if he were to win in New
York you know I think there was a little
bit of jokes made that part of the Jets
pitch was you could be a future Hall of
Famer and everyone said hahaha Derek
Carr he's not a future no no no the New
York Jets do not believe Derek Carr is a
first round ballad Hall of Famer right
now but if he wins in New York with this
team I could see where Ray but perhaps
they had that belief in him
um so that was that was part of their
cell there uh they obviously don't need
to sell the Hall of Fame aspect to Aaron
Rodgers he's there but could Derek Carr
have had this job if he wanted it
could he be the quarterback of the jet
I think there was a time when this was
going to work out there was a time when
both sides were very interested in one
another uh I don't think they made it
um you know
completely down the aisle uh but it was
looking like it was going in that
direction Dan and and I was a little
surprised it didn't to be to be very
honest with you
um
and that window closed the time in terms
of when New York wanted
an answer and another window remained
open and that window was
the world of Aaron Rodgers and from what
I can gather the Jets felt that they had
enough information about Aaron Rodgers
is interest in them
for them to then continue conversations
reach out to the Packers
um have discussions of compensation and
then eventually owner Woody Johnson
getting everybody on board a jet to fly
out west to sit in front of Aaron what
do you think the compensation is going
to be for Rogers with the Packers
you know
I've been I've been trying to get the
actual facts but
um
I here's something that could happen I
could see them perhaps not getting a
first rounder out of this which when I
first heard that I like it actually kind
of blew my mind
um because to think about the value they
could get for him
um but I don't Dan I don't sense from
Green Bay that they're asking for the
for the moon and the stars here yeah I
think they're being really fair with the
Jets now I do think the interesting part
of this is going to be the contract
that's what I want to know I want to see
if this actually they're able to get the
ball over the goal line here and bring
in the big fish to New York what is an
Aaron Rodgers contracts gonna look like
knowing Woody Johnson wants to spend the
money I spent some time with Woody a few
weeks ago in Arizona and we had all
these conversations about what he's
looking for and I didn't have to direct
too much he was very open
they know they need a veteran and they
need someone who can come in here and
just go that they don't want to
um have to support in any other way they
want to start and it's why they went
after Aaron
Mike Tannenbaum who have great respect
for former Jets GM said that he would
offer Aaron Rodgers back loaded so it'd
be yeah if I did 30 million then I would
do 60 million for Year too because if
I'm the Jets do I want Aaron Rodgers for
just one year that you're all in for one
year and you're going to try to win a
Super Bowl and then convince him to stay
and then all of a sudden you're in a
Packers situation here
no no exactly I I understand Mike's
theory on it and I also have tremendous
respect for him because he's done the
job and we saw what he he did it with
Brett Favre
um but I don't think that's going to be
good enough for an Aaron Rodgers in
terms of money
let's go back even a year ago Dan when
when we were all trying to figure out
what kind of money Aaron was looking for
and from the conversations I had back
then I recalled it being very clear he
wanted to be the highest paid
quarterback and even though he denied
that he wanted 50 million he went on
McAfee said no that's not true
guess what Aaron Rodgers got paid 50
million dollars right so he likes money
and he should we all do I don't have
enough money to have my own office so I
again I just
I don't think New York is going to be
able to pull anything on him inter I
think this is still recruiting and if
they're going to lean into that they're
going to want to give him a lot of money
to to make sure he knows he's coming to
New York and he's going to be taken care
of when's the decision expected
so the last
um Source I spoke with today in New York
is there they are waiting for Aaron so
that's what the holdup is so
compensation's still being worked out I
heard that it's they're still kind of
going back and forth on some things but
they feel good they're going to get
there this is now Aaron so here I am
talking to you right on Thursday
afternoon and I'm like they feel so good
the Jets are ready you know number 12 is
hanging the flag is hanging from the
Brooklyn Bridge to my right it's it's
not really but Mike Greenberg might as
well go do it
um
we're not there yet but the Jets have
done everything absolutely everything
they possibly can do as an NFL team to
try to lure the future Hall of Famer
okay I'll leave you with this I don't
mean to be a buzz kill let's say they
don't get Aaron Rodgers in New York
foreign
Garoppolo
he would be the next well first of all
I I you didn't ask me who the next
quarterback you just made a statement
there was no question there who do you
think could be the next quarterback if
they don't get here
as a girl that lives in New Jersey my
response to your statement of oh my it
would be like oh my God like at this
point the Jets are so far in the stand
that
look if you're a Jets fan you have to be
at least happy your team is trying but
the the
soul-crushing reality of them dropping
the ball on this or perhaps they're not
even dropping the ball but if Aaron were
to turn around and go oh you know I'm
gonna just retire I I I can't
um I don't know if there's been pain
like that in New York in a long time
um
in fact I'm trying to think in my head
right now like when was the last time
New York was just absolutely crushed
some would argue that Daniel Jones
contract but
um
but look that being said I think the
next move would be would be exploring
the Jimmy Garoppolo market and and
you've gotta I don't know this for a
fact so you know but I would think that
Lamar Jackson would be something that
they would have to look into as well
because that that's something that they
can make work there in that offense
you've done a great job and uh thank you
and I uh I text Stephen A and told him
that you were in his office and uh
he's probably gonna have some words for
you uh oh we just lost her uh oh Stephen
amen Steven A may have pulled the plug
on her there thank you Diana if you can
hear me Diana Rossini of the Mothership